When Senator Elizabeth Warren delivered a speech at a campaign event in Atlanta last November,
charter school supports showed up
to make their voices heard.
Sarah Carpenter, a grandmother and school choice activist, who had traveled six hours from Memphis
to attend the event, confronted Warren backstage.
That clip went viral because Warren wasn't
telling the truth.
Three weeks earlier an education researcher named Corey DeAngelis
had discovered through online sleuthing that her son Alex Warren, now 43, had attended Kirby Hall,
an elite private school in Austin.
DeAngelis, who is the director of school choice at the Reason Foundation,
the nonprofit that publishes Reason TV,
decided to research the issue because Warren wasn't forthcoming with reporters.
A few journalists actually asked all the democratic presidential candidates
where they sent their own kids to school, and where they went to school, just as some descriptive
analysis and reporting, which is very interesting.
And going through that I saw that Elizabeth
Warren did respond to their email and said that
she went to public schools in Oklahoma,
but the campaign said no response on the question of
where she sent her own kids to school.
So I started thinking a little bit, you know,
if she's so public school proud,
and that she's bragging about how she went to public schools, and how she taught at public school,
she'd probably be really proud to talk about how she sent her own kids to public schools
if that was actually the case.